[Musique]
elle a choisi la ville des mureaux pour
son premier déplacement la première
ministre elisabeth borgne s'est rendu au
pôle molière elle a rencontré des
associations qui agissent en faveur de
l'égalité des chances et de
l'émancipation des femmes depuis
plusieurs jours l'eau manque aux
cultures yvelinoise une période de
sécheresse qui commence à inquiéter les
agriculteurs conséquence une perte de
rendement pour certaines exploitations
ou un manque de nourriture pour les
élevages la ville de ben se lance à la
recherche d'un éco garde communale une
première dans les yvelines son rôle
sensibiliser et valoriser les espaces
naturels de la ville il pourra également
verbaliser les incivilités de jeunes
entrepreneurs proposent un nouveau
concept nommé la tournée une livraison
quotidienne dans le nord yvelines de
boissons avec des bouteilles continuer
le but réduire les déchets et remettre
la consigne au goût du jour première
phase de restauration terminée pour le
château de dampierre en yvelines elle a
été marquée par la dépose du filet de
chantier et puis enfin la finale du
championnat de france unss de handball
se déroulait au gymnase mont boron à
versailles victoire du lycée saint
joseph de toulouse 24 à 23 contre le
lycée saint cricq de pau le sport
scolaire à l'honneur aussi avec les
gymnases yade qui ont réuni 500 jeunes à
rambouillet
[Musique]
pas